Music Everybody's smartless now, everybody's smartless now Come on in and smartless with me Oh my god he did it, oh my god he did it You can just hear radios turning off right now Welcome to smartless! Music So Jay, when you wash your hands, I've heard you refer to it before as boiling them
Music 大家现在都变得冰雪聪明了，大家现在都变得冰雪聪明了，快来和我一起聪明逗趣吧。天呐，他真的做到了，天呐，他真的做到了。你现在就能听到收音机纷纷关掉的声音。欢迎收看《聪明逗趣》！Music 所以，杰伊，当你洗手的时候，我以前听你提到过，你说那叫把它们煮沸。
Yes, sure, well, but I don't, you know, I mean, if I don't boil them, that would kill a lot more than the germs I don't even wash my hands with hot water Sure, sure, you don't need to anymore Hot water, it's a myth, right? The hot water does not help you with germs Oh is that true? I didn't hear that No, yeah it doesn't So I'm gonna just do it in cold water now And also eggs, eggs don't give you a cholesterol problem
对，没错，当然，但是，你知道我的意思，如果我不把它们煮沸，那杀死的细菌可就少得多了。我甚至都不用热水洗手。当然，当然，你不需要了。热水，这纯属无稽之谈，对吧？热水根本帮你杀不死细菌。哦，真的吗？我没听说过。不，对，确实没用。所以我现在要用冷水洗了。还有鸡蛋，鸡蛋不会引发胆固醇问题。
This is true It's also a myth They were on and they were bad and now they're back on Wait a second, we've talked about this before But it's not in the same ballpark as the washing of your hand Are you just talking about myths in general? Yeah, well, you know, you're not gonna have hair on your palms if you masturbate I mean, what are we doing here? Are we just going through the list?
是真的。这也是个无稽之谈。它们曾一度被认为是不好的，而现在又重新被接受了。等等，我们以前讨论过这个。但它和洗手根本不是一回事。你只是在泛指各种无稽之谈吗？对，好吧，你知道的，手淫不会让你的手心长毛。我的意思是，我们这是在干什么？我们是在逐一列举吗？
I don't know, but you, I think you can over-electrolite yourself like you do Go ahead, Jason, talk right now What are you talking about? Unbelievable with the eating Well, at least I do it when someone else is talking No, but you know what, after all this time and the shaming that you've done with me with the eating You know what else I'm doing? I'm moving my head away from the microphone When I chew, another trick you don't do
我不知道，不过你，我觉得你可能会像平时那样电解质过量。说吧，杰森，现在就说。你在说什么？吃东西的声音简直不可思议。好吧，至少我是在别人说话的时候吃。不，但你知道吗，经过这么长时间，还有你一直以来对我吃东西的羞辱。你知道我还在做什么吗？我在把头移开麦克风。当我咀嚼时，这是你不会的另一个小把戏。
Except for now You can go ahead and keep it there Yeah, you need to get your point across You made your point across while your mouth was full of food Oh, God, what a sad sight Do we get to our guest for God's sake? I know, but last thing, can't you over-electrolite? Can't you over-hydrate? If you want to hear something honest, I'm honesting right now
除了现在。你可以继续把它放在那儿。是的，你需要把你的观点表达清楚。你趁嘴里塞满食物的时候把观点表达清楚了。哦，天呐，真是一幅令人心酸的景象。看在上帝的份上，我们能进入采访嘉宾的环节了吗？我知道，但最后一件事，电解质真的会过量吗？水分真的会补充过度吗？如果你想听实话，我现在就在实话实说。
Here, I'm gonna honest with you I was, you know, I'm very conscious of my puff factor on my face Yeah, I got it We are too We're very aware too And I was noticing I was holding quite a bit of water And I was like, I'm not eating salt or sugar Because those are the big puffers for me
来吧，我对你实话实说。我当时，你知道的，我对自已脸部的浮肿程度非常敏感。好吧，我懂。我们也一样。我们也意识得很清楚。我当时注意到我体内存留了相当多的水分，然后我就想，我没吃盐也没吃糖。因为对我来说，这些都是大肿脸元凶。
And of course, I haven't had a sip of alcohol for 20 years And so I was like, it's gotta be these goddamn electrolytes I did a deep dive on the internet to see if electrolytes Because it would stand a reason Because you're trying to replace salts and sodium I'm like, God, I figured it out And that's not it Oh, it's not it, what a story
当然，我已经20滴酒未沾了。所以我就想，肯定是因为这些该死的电解质。我在网上深入研究了一下，看看电解质是不是因为这合乎情理。因为你在试图补充盐分和钠。我心想，天哪，我找到原因了。结果并不是这样。哦，原来不是这样，真是个故事。
So it's just your face It's just my face Oh, no Because you've explained before that your people needed to hold on to water Because in Malta, when you're pulling up the fish The fish, because sometimes it'll get cold out there in the Mediterranean I think it's actually from the other side of my family That probably grew up in some sort of iceberg somewhere
所以只是你的脸？只是我的脸。哦，不。因为你之前解释过，你们祖先需要保留水分。因为在马耳他，当你把鱼拉上来的时候。鱼，因为地中海有时候天气会变冷。我觉得这其实来自我家族的另一支。他们可能是在某个冰山附近长大的。
That they had to hold on to, you know, a lot of fat and water To insulate themselves Have you thought about doing a victory lap down in Malta? Just getting and letting the Maltese get a look at you Call him the Maltese Falcon Well, to say that I'm a countryman and be proud of me Yeah, do you think this... No, no, sorry
他们必须保留大量的脂肪和水分。来给自己保温。你有没有想过在马耳他搞一次载誉归来的巡游？去让马耳他人好好看一看你。管他叫马耳他之鹰。好吧，去证明我是个同胞，为我感到骄傲。是的，你觉得这个……不，不，抱歉。
Excuse you You know what that sound was? That was the sound of our mystery guest pushing away from the table in their chair Saying, that's enough I'm out of here You know, this is a good time to talk about our mystery guest Because our guest today has emerged as a true treasure in this country Our guest is a very, very funny person
失陪一下。你知道刚才那个声音是什么吗？那是我们的神秘嘉宾在椅子上把桌子推开的声音。嘴里说着：“够了，我不干了。”你知道的，现在正是聊聊我们神秘嘉宾的好时机。因为我们今天的嘉宾已经成为这个国家的真正宝藏。我们的嘉宾是一个非常非常有趣的人。
Our guest is an Angelino Oh, born and raised in Los Angeles Our guest came out of, it seemed like was like shot out of a cannon Into the comedy scene a few years ago And before you knew it, this person was everywhere And the top of every list to make every television program in every movie Just like overnight, by the way, not overnight because... We need to have a guest session
我们的嘉宾是个洛杉矶人。哦，在洛杉矶土生土长。我们的嘉宾一出场，感觉就像是从大炮里发射出来的一样。几年前闯入喜剧界。没过多久，这个人就无处不在了。成了制作每档电视节目和每部电影时首选名单上的常客。就像是一夜成名一样，顺便说一句，其实不是一夜成名，因为……我们需要进行一次嘉宾竞猜。
Let's guess on this one Yeah, I would like to guess Amy Schumer Okay, and Jason That's a great guess Michael Malley Another great guest Two very funny people This person is an incredibly funny person
我们来猜猜这个人吧。好啊，我来猜，艾米·舒默。好的，还有杰森。真是个绝佳的猜测。迈克尔·马利。又一个绝佳的猜测。两个非常有趣的人。这个人是一个极其有趣的人。
Who first came to prominence on The Carmichael Show That was the breakthrough This person is a stand-up comedian This person then published... Won an Emmy Award for her hosting of Saturday Night Live She published a memoir called The Last Black Unicorn She starts in a TV series called The Last OG She executive produces and voices Tuka and Birdie
她最初因出演《卡梅尔秀》而崭露头角。那是她的重大突破。这个人是一位单口喜剧演员。这个人随后出版了……因主持《周六夜现场》而赢得艾美奖。她出版了一本回忆录，名为《最后的黑独角兽》。她主演了一部名为《最后的大佬》的电视剧。她担任执行制片并为《图卡和伯蒂》配音。
Tuka and Birdie on Netflix Adult Swim She won a Grammy Award for her best comedy album For her album Black Mitzvah And she only made it the second African-American woman To win this prize after Whoopi Goldberg This person is none other than one of my favorite co-stars From Lego Movie 2, Tiffany Haddish, I had it
Netflix成人游泳频道的《图卡和伯蒂》。她凭喜剧专辑《黑弥撒》赢得了格莱美奖最佳喜剧专辑奖。她也成为了仅有的第二位获得此殊荣的非裔美国女性，仅次于乌比·戈德堡。这个人不是别人，正是我的《乐高大电影2》中最喜欢的联合主演之一，蒂凡尼·哈迪斯，我猜中了。
You should have let me guess it Look at Tiffany Hello fellas, how are you today? Wow Listener, we've got a blonde Tiffany Haddish Wow It's a hard hat, honey I'm here for work
你刚才真该让我猜的。看看蒂凡尼。哈喽，伙计们，你们今天过得怎么样？哇。听众朋友们，我们迎来了一个金发碧眼的蒂凡尼·哈迪斯。哇。这是安全帽，亲爱的。我是来工作的。
Is it for work? It's for work And what is the part? Working with you I'm appropriating the white culture I'm playing a white woman Please do Please do
是为了工作吗？是为了工作。什么角色？和你们一起工作。我在挪用白人文化。我在扮演一个白人女性。请便。请便。
Y'all the smartest and funniest That's the only reason I showed up Because I'm gonna tell you right now I was like, it's too early I had my only day off It's my only day off Wait, what are you working on right now? Success and prosperity
你们是最聪明也是最搞笑的。这就是我赶来的唯一原因。因为我直接告诉你们吧，我当时觉得，太早了。那是我唯一的休息日。那是我的唯一的休息日。等等，你现在在忙什么？成功与繁荣。
There it is Okay, but there it is Abundance and generational wealth That's what I'm working on Oh, yeah But as I ask, what are you working on? You really do have Always 18,000 projects going on
这不就来了。好吧，但就是这个。富足与世代财富。这就是我正在努力追求的。哦，对。不过我还是想问，你到底在忙什么？你真的总是。同时进行着1.8万个项目。
You work so hard all the time I do get away one week out of the month I'll go to Panama or somewhere I'm loving Panama right now Do you go to Panama for the She likes watching the ships go by I'm going there, I want to start a farm I want to own a farm
你总是这么拼命工作。我确实每个月会抽出一周的时间离开。我会去巴拿马或者别的地方。我现在超爱巴拿马。你去巴拿马是为了……她喜欢看船只缓缓驶过。我要去那儿，我想开辟一个农场。我想拥有一个农场。
In Panama? Yeah, I want to grow pineapples I want to grow coconuts I want to grow jackfruit and soursop What's soursop? It's the best freaking fruit you've ever had in your life Full of auto nutrients and everything you need It's a tropical fruit
在巴拿马？对，我想种菠萝。我想种椰子。我想种菠萝蜜和红毛榴莲。什么是红毛榴莲？那是你这辈子吃过最好吃的倒霉水果。富含超级营养和你需要的一切。这是一种热带水果。
It's like a dragon's egg And when you eat it, it fills you up With all the nutrients and everything that you need For the day What's it called? Soursop And it has properties that heal cancer That cure it like
它就像一颗龙蛋。当你吃下它时，它会为你补充满满的营养。以及你当天所需的一切。它叫什么？红毛榴莲。它还具有治疗癌症的特性。能治愈它，就像……
I wouldn't say cure I don't want to get murdered by the drugs It's like antioxidants They'll push it off for a few years It has everything you need to make your body heal itself Really good on blood pressure You know, black people have blood pressure It's crazy and that soursop really regulates it
我不会说能治愈。我可不想被药物行业谋杀。它就像抗氧化剂一样。它们会让病情推迟几年。它拥有让你的身体自我治愈所需的一切。对控制血压非常有效。你知道的，黑人都有血压问题。这太疯狂了，而那红毛榴莲真的能调节血压。
The world we live in right now People are going to take this clip of you saying That they're going to be like Tiffany Haddish claims to cure cancer with this fruit And then it's just going to be Let's hope Let's hope Now, do you have wanderlust?
我们现在生活的这个世界。人们会截取你这段说的话。然后他们就会说，蒂凡尼·哈迪斯声称这种水果可以治愈癌症。然后事情就会变成这样。但愿如此。但愿如此。那么，你对远方充满渴望吗？
Are you good about flying around the world And exploring new places? That's something I'd like to get better at I'm working on it I'm working on it When the first time I went to Panama My mind was blown I knew that there was like
你很喜欢四处飞世界各地并探索新地方吗？这是我想做得更好的事情。我正在努力。我正在努力。我第一次去巴拿马的时候。我的大脑都被震撼了。我知道有这样的。
Some Spanish people that have dark skin That speak Spanish, right? Because I live in LA But I didn't realize That there were people that looked like they were straight off Of the continent of Africa Mixed with nothing But just straight up African
有些西班牙裔人皮肤黝黑。会说西班牙语，对吧？因为我住在洛杉矶。但我没有意识到。竟然还有人看起来就像是直接从。非洲大陆走出来的一样。没跟任何人混血。就是纯正的非洲血统。
That speak Spanish the way they do And just celebrate life the way they do And it's so relaxing Oh my god It's where the Pacific and the Atlantic Ocean meet And there's no military there Right? Because it's a sanction
他们说西班牙语的方式，以及他们庆祝生活的方式，都太让人放松了。哦，天呐。那是太平洋和大西洋交汇的地方。那里没有军队，对吧？因为那是个特区。
Something Because all the goods from all over the world Go through the Panama Canal Which originally they were going to build it through Nicaragua And then they started that project and they abandoned it And they did Panama True story Right
有什么原因吧。因为来自世界各地的所有货物。都要通过巴拿马运河。他们原本最初打算通过尼加拉瓜修建运河。然后他们启动了那个项目，又放弃了。最后选择了巴拿马。千真万确。没错。
Which a lot of islanders A lot of Haitians and Jamaicans and Africans Built that canal That was a pretty audacious idea Right? Just carve Let's just cut this whole area right here And we'll connect
当年有大量的岛民。有大量的海地人、牙买加人和非洲人。修建了那条运河。那真是一个相当大胆的想法。对吧？直接劈开。让我们直接把这整片区域切开。然后我们就能连通。
I've always thought I'd like to do banking In Panama Oh yeah Yeah I'd like to do it I'm gonna do it I'm gonna open up a bank Yeah open up a bank Haddish federal
我一直觉得我想去巴拿马做银行业务。哦，是的。对。我想去那儿搞金融。我要去干这个。我要去开一家银行。对，开一家银行。哈迪斯联邦银行。
There is a lot of money laundering Happening down in Panama I guess that's what I'm saying They got US dollars down there They deal in all US dollars I'd love to get in some money laundering Jason will give us some tips I'm not in the business of dry cleaning money
巴拿马现在有很多洗钱活动。我想这就是我想说的。他们那里有美元。他们全用美元交易。我很乐意参与一些洗钱活动。杰森会给我们一些建议。我不干干洗黑钱的买卖。
But I will make sure it's clean Yeah just call Marty Bird he'll take care of it for you Have you ever seen Jason's show The Ozarks there? Have you ever seen it? Yes I freaking love that show Me and my man sit up and watch it We ready for the next season I know it's great
但我会确保钱是干净的。对，给马蒂·伯德打个电话，他会帮你搞定的。你从来没看过杰森的剧《黑钱胜地》吗？你看过吗？看过。我超级喜欢那部剧。我和我男人坐在一起看。我们已经准备好迎接下一季了。我知道这剧太棒了。
And your man if you've been living under a rock Your man is common That's his name I like him What a nice man I love him I was in a movie with him I was in
如果你一直与世隔绝的话，你的男人就是Common。那是他的名字。我很喜欢他。多好的一个男人啊。我爱他。我曾和他一起拍过电影。我演过……
Oh boy now I'm blanking on it Oh my god We were Pella talking about it I don't remember what the name was But he said that you were awesome to work with I met him once up in Canada Smokinacus Smokinacus
哦，天呐，现在我脑子一片空白。哦，天呐。我们在佩拉谈过这个。我不记得片名叫什么了。但他说和你一起工作感觉棒极了。我在加拿大碰过他一次。斯莫基纳库斯。斯莫基纳库斯。
My friend is so bad nowadays He's very cool He's such a talented dude He's a great actor And a nice nice nice man I've never met him I would kill to meet him I'm a huge fan of both of you How long have you guys been together?
我的朋友现在太棒了。他非常酷。他是个极有天赋的家伙。他是个伟大的演员。而且是个很好很好很好的人。我从没见过他。我做梦都想见他。我是你们俩的超级粉丝。你们俩在一起多久了？
It's been a year Where's he? Why don't you wake his ass up And drag him into the frame Well no he's at his house And I'm at my house I went to sleep at his house And then I came to my This is where I work my house
已经一年了。他在哪儿？你为什么不把他那屁股叫醒，把他拉到镜头里来呢？哦，不，他在他家。我在我家。我在他家睡的觉。然后我来了我……这是我工作的地方，我的我家。
And then I do the other stuff at his house I got you Alright now what are you guys going to do later on today? What type of stuff do you guys like to do on the weekends? What's day plans look like For Tiffany and Common? I think he's going into the studio I'm going to go do a comedy show
然后我在他家做别的事。我懂了。好吧，你们今天晚些时候打算做什么？你们俩周末喜欢做什么类型的事情？蒂凡尼和Common一天的计划是什么样的？我想他要去录音室。我要去表演一场喜剧秀。
On a rooftop off of Wilshire Boulevard At about two o'clock And then Well I'm going to go there at one In the show and I go on at two thirty Stand up And then so I'm going to get a little litty And eat good
在威尔希尔大道的一个屋顶上。大约两点钟。然后……好吧，我要一点钟去到那儿。看演出，我两点半上台。单口喜剧。然后我要稍微喝嗨一点。然后大吃一顿。
Do my show And then I'm going to go from there And I'm going to go to the Jungle Cruise premiere Wow awesome I want to see that So it's kind of a work day for you You don't mind your weekends being a work day No I feel like this is an opportunity day
演完我的脱口秀。然后我就从那儿出发。我要去参加《森林奇航》的首映礼。哇，太棒了。我想看那部电影。所以这对你来说算是工作日咯。你不介意周末当成工作日吗？不，我觉得这是个充满机遇的日子。
This is a day to talk to people That I really want to work with Nice Like all three of you are guys That I really would like to work with Will I already work with you So whatever But everybody else
这是个与我非常想合作的人交谈的日子。太好了。就像你们三个人都是。我真的很想合作的人。威利，我已经跟你合作过了。所以无所谓。但其他人……
It wasn't that great Yeah likewise Tiff did you grow up in L.A. your whole life? Yeah Yeah And always loved it Never wanted to live somewhere else For a little bit
没那么好。是的，彼此彼此。蒂凡尼，你是在洛杉矶长大的吗？对。对。一直都很喜欢这里？从来没想过要去其他地方住一段时间吗？
I used to go to Atlanta To visit my friend in school And I wanted to live there for a little bit And then I realized I don't want to live there Because No thank you No
我以前经常去亚特兰大。看望在那儿上学的朋。友，我曾想在那里住上一小段时间。然后我意识到我不想住在那里。因为……不用了，谢谢。不。
Yeah tell me Because I spent a lot of time in Atlanta You tell me Because I mean I mean I love it here in L.A. But if I had to work somewhere else Atlanta is just great people Great crews
对，跟我讲讲。因为我在亚特兰大呆了很长时间。你来告诉我。因为，我的意思是，我很喜欢洛杉矶。但如果我必须在其他地方工作。亚特兰大的人真的很棒。剧组也很棒。
Incredible restaurant Bubble bubble bubble bubble What is it about that city For you that was like L.A. would be better The men are crazy Are they The men are not necessarily
不可思议的餐厅。咕噜咕噜咕噜咕噜。那个城市有什么吸引你的地方，让你觉得洛杉矶更好？那里的男人太疯狂了。是吗？那些男人不一定……
I'm used to L.A. dudes That's like you know They like get at you And then they realize you're not the one And they just disappear But in Atlanta They kind of stalkerish Oh they'll just straight up follow you
我习惯了洛杉矶的男人。他们就像是，你知道的。他们会主动搭讪。然后他们发现你不是那块料。然后他们就直接消失了。但在亚特兰大。他们有点像跟踪狂。哦，他们会直接尾随你。
In L.A. they are very aggressive They grabbing ass They grabbing your arms Like it's just Just no And you'd rather know where you Like you're not on an actual hunt Like you can communicate with me
在洛杉矶，他们非常具有攻击性。他们会抓屁股。他们会抓你的胳膊。就像是……简直了……就是不要。你宁愿知道你在哪里。就像你不是在真正被围猎一样。你可以跟我沟通。
Use your words to catch me You don't gotta actually grab me You know what I'm saying Like don't get your motherfucking hands off me And I'm a fighter So like you grab me I got PTSD too If you just snatch me up
用你的语言来吸引我。你实际上没必要抓我。你知道我在说什么吗？别把你的脏手从我身上拿开。而且我可是个练家子。所以你抓我的话……我也有创伤后应激障碍。如果你直接把我强行拉走。
I'm gonna first assess the situation Are they shooting No Oh you just grab me I start fighting I would catch a case Right Let's go around the room here
我会先评估一下局势。他们在开枪吗？没有。哦，你只是抓了我一下。我开始反击了。我可能会惹上官司。对。让我们在场的每个人都来聊聊。
We'll start with you Tiffany When's the last time You actually threw a punch And it landed on someone Actually the last time I threw a punch And it landed on someone Cause the last time I threw a punch It missed
我们从你开始，蒂凡尼。你上一次。真正出拳。并且打中某人是什么时候？其实是我上一次出拳。并且打中某人。因为我上上次出拳。打偏了。
But When I did night school I punched Kevin I didn't mean to But I did Okay that counts So that was like three years ago Well last time you threw a punch
但是。当我上夜校的时候。我打了凯文。我不是故意的。但我确实打了。好吧，那算数。所以那大概是三年前吧。好吧，你上一次出拳。
The last time Fourth grade No I was 21 I got in a fight in a bar In New York You remember whether you won or lost I won Good for you
上一次。四年级。不对，我21岁时。我在纽约的一家酒吧里打过一架。你还记得你是赢了还是输了？我赢了。为你高兴。
I think it was the only time I ever won You lose a lot of It was my last one I went out of winter Did you get any fights When you were playing hockey Like throwing off the gloves No no no
我想那是我唯一一次赢。你输了很多……那是我最后一次。我退出了冬季……你们打过架吗？当你打冰球的时候。就像扔掉手套那样。没有，没有。
I was a little kid No no no I wasn't like that When I was a little kid But I did one time I was doing a scene And I was supposed to And I was supposed to
我当时是个小孩。不，不，我不是那样的。当我还是个小孩的时候。但我有一次。我当时在拍一场戏。我本应该……我本应该。
Miss the guy by a lot And I was like Kind of had him down And my elbow caught him You threw a haddish And yeah I threw a haddish And I caught him pretty good
狠狠地打偏那个家伙。然后我当时……差不多把他按倒了。我的胳膊肘打中了他。你使出一招“哈迪斯重击”。对，我使出一招“哈迪斯重击”。而且我打得相当准。
And I kind of like looked down Like oh shit But we just kept rolling And God bless this guy He kept going with this stunt guy He took it And then cut And then immediately I ran back
我有点像往下看了一眼。心想，噢靠。但我们还是继续拍摄。上帝保佑这家伙。他继续坚持了下来，这个特技演员。他硬扛下来了。然后“咔——停”。接着我立刻跑了回去。
I'm like Jesus Christ I'm so Did they end up using that take No they cut the whole scene No they cut the whole scene I felt bad for him Cause he caught my elbow He got hit for nothing
我说，天呐。我太……他们最后用了那个镜头吗？没有，他们把整场戏都剪掉了。不，他们把整场戏都剪掉了。我真为他感到难过。因为他挨了我的胳膊肘。他白挨了一下。
Sean when's the last time You threw a punch And Scotty doesn't count I haven't thrown a punch ever I drank some punch For breakfast this morning That counts That does count
肖恩，你上一次出拳是什么时候？斯科蒂不算。我从来没有出过拳。我喝了点潘趣酒。今天早上当早餐。这算数。这算数。
But no but When I was doing three stooges I had to throw I had to hit this guy With a Like a shovel thing And it was made of rubber of course But the top of it was metal
但是，没有，但是。当我拍摄《三个臭皮匠》的时候。我得出一拳。我得用一个东西打这个家伙。像个铲子一样的东西。当然它是橡胶做的。但顶部是金属的。
And it hit him right smack dab In the middle of the forehead And cut his head open Yeah And cut his head open Third eye you busted his third eye Yeah his third eye yeah The only punch is that you guys
结果它狠狠地砸在他。正中央的额头上。把他的头打破了。对。把他的头打破了。第三只眼，你打破了他的第三只眼。对，他的第三只眼，对。你们出过的唯一的拳。
Have thrown that have all been set stories Hollywood stories from acting Or pathetic Well didn't you want me to call out The real stories The real fights I had Yeah of course Me and my sister we had a squabble
全都是剧本里的情节。演戏时的好莱坞故事。还是说很逊。好吧，难道不是你让我讲讲。真实的故事吗？我打过的真正的架。是的，当然。我和我姐姐曾起过争执。
About six years ago Sisters can go huh Yeah and then I definitely punched my brother In the chest No when you fight a girl Are you allowed to grab the hair Yeah
大约六年前。姐妹之间嘛，哼。对，然后我绝对是在胸口上。狠狠地打了我哥哥一拳。不对，当你和女孩打架时。你可以抓头发吗？对。
I feel like that's a little unfair No it's not Okay Everything is a fight It's about whooping ass Yeah So snatch that here You snatch it here
我觉得这有点不公平。不，这很公平。好吧。一切都是为了打架。这全关于把对方打得屁滚尿流。对。所以去扯那头发。你扯住头发。
And you botch botch botch In a face like that You hold the head with one hand And you grab the shirt So you can get a guy down on the ground I once I was best friends with the guy For a couple of years
然后狠狠地往脸上招呼。你用一只手固定住头部。然后抓住衬衫。这样你就能把对方按倒在地上。有一次，我和一个家伙是最好的朋友。维持了好几年。
So I thought I knew him pretty well And then we were at a bar And he got into it with some guy And the guy said let's go outside And my buddy said great fine So we all followed him outside And my buddy walks out there And the first thing he does
所以我以为我很了解他。然后我们在一家酒吧里。他和某个家伙起了冲突。那家伙说我们去外面吧。我的死党说，好啊，没问题。于是我们都跟着他去了外面。我的死党走出去。他做的第一件事是……
He pulls off his shirt And he says okay let's go And I was like what the fuck What's that move Taken off your shirt And I realized You take off your shirt So the guy can't grab you
他脱掉了自己的衬衫。然后他说，好吧，我们上吧。我当时就想，卧槽。这是什么招式？脱掉衬衫。我这才意识到。你脱掉衬衫。是为了让对方无法抓住你。
And get an unfair advantage And I was like Jesus Christ That's strong Next time I get in a fight I'm taking off my shirt And I'll be like let's go bitches Yeah that's strong Like it's not earrings and fingernails
从而占据不公平的优势。我当时想，天呐。这太强了。下次我打架时。我也要把衬衫脱掉。我会说，来吧，婊子们。对，这太强了。就像，这可不是扯耳环和抓指甲。
It's shirt comes off Yeah That would be like I'm gonna take my wig off Yeah I'm not fucking with her My wig off You hoes don't know What you mess with you
这是直接脱衬衫。对。这就好比我要把假发摘了。对，我可不惹她。我的假发摘下来。你们这群碧池根本不知道。你们在惹什么人。
Yeah hold the phone Let me take my heart out Because you ain't fucking that up Jason do you think you'd ever be mad enough To take your wig off No no no Jason no I didn't think Wait
对，等等。让我把心掏出来。因为你们可搞砸不起这个。杰森，你觉得你有一天会愤怒到。把假发摘下来吗？不，不，不。杰森，我没想过。等等。
I take my wig off her swim team That's it Let me so Tiffany talking about All that sort of stuff I mean you don't fight anymore That much I don't imagine I mean I would fight if I had to If somebody hit me first
我把她的游泳队假发摘了。就这样。好了，让蒂凡尼谈谈。所有这些乱七八糟的事。我是说你现在不怎么打架了吧。我猜是的。我的意思是，如果我必须打，我就会打。如果有人先动手打我。
They better knock me the fuck out Because I'm all the rage All the angry back women Gonna come out All the anger from all the years All the nose is gonna rise up From my ovaries And shoot at them
他们最好把我狠狠打晕。因为我积攒的怒火。所有愤怒的黑人女性的情绪。都要爆发出来了。多年来积压的所有怒火。都要从我的卵巢里升腾起来。向他们发射过去。
I'm gonna turn it to one of them Mortal Kombat characters Why are you acting like that But I can't fight no more Because they say they gonna sue you People will sue you for whatever And it's like When they put their hands on me first
我要变成《真人快打》里的角色。你为什么表现得像那样？但我不能再打架了。因为他们说他们会起诉你。人们会为了任何事起诉你。这就好比。当他们先对我动手动脚。
And I'm afraid for my life So now instead of fighting You laugh This is kind of what I'm getting to Which is like I use my words You use your words And you came up
而我又感到生命受到威胁。所以现在与其打架。不如大笑。这正是我要说的。那就是我用我的语言。你用你的语言。你出身于……
You're from Los Angeles You grew up in South Central What was that leap How do you become a huge superstar That you are today What's that first step to Getting into comedy From where you grew up
你来自洛杉矶。你在中南区长大。那是一次怎样的跨越？你是如何成为今天的超级巨星的？从你长大的地方。迈入喜剧界的第一步是什么？
Because that's a big leap, right? Yeah, it's a huge leap Well, first step is I watched this movie Who Framed Roger Rabbit And there's a scene in a movie Where the detective says to the rabbit Why are all these people
因为那是个巨大的跨越，对吧？对，这是一个巨大的跨越。嗯，第一步是我看了这部电影《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》。电影里有一个场景。侦探对兔子说。为什么所有这些人。
Doing these nice things for you He said because I make them laugh, Eddie If you make people laugh They'll do anything for you So I was like That's how I'm gonna get help With my homework That's how I'm gonna get people
都要对你这么好？兔子说，因为我能让他们笑，埃迪。如果你能让人发笑。他们会为你做任何事。所以我当时就想。我要用这一招来获取帮助。帮我写家庭作业。我要用这一招让人们。
To do things for me So I was just The silliest and funniest kid In school And I was already very shy So I was like forcing this To be funny Were you really?
为我做事。所以我简直成了。学校里最傻气最搞笑的孩子。而我本身又非常害羞。所以我当时是在强迫自己。去表现得搞笑。你真的是吗？
Yes, I was very shy As a little girl Because there was a lot going on In my world But when I came into school I walk in like Okay, this is the funny thing That's gonna happen
对，我小时候非常害羞。因为我的世界里发生了太多事情。但当我走进学校时。我走进去就像是……好吧，这就是那件搞笑的事。接下来要发生了。
I mean, I would plot and scheme The funny things I would do And say the night before The things I would wear And all of this So that I could be funny And I could get people To let me copy their homework
我的意思是，我会策划和密谋。我前一天晚上要做和说的搞笑事情。我要穿的衣服。以及所有这一切。这样我才能变得搞笑。我才能让别人。让我抄他们的作业。
And let me cheat off their test Get them to read things to me And memorize it Like, I was very manipulative Where'd you get your sense of humor from? Was it one of your parents Or a sibling or watching TV Or movies?
让我从他们的考试中作弊。让他们读东西给我听。然后我把它背下来。是的，我非常工于心计。你的幽默感是从哪儿来的？是来自你的父母。还是某个兄弟姐妹，或者看电视。
My mom was pretty funny She was always telling stories And stuff My grandma was hilarious And I feel like TV Gave me everything You know what I mean? I would always try to copy
还是看电影？我妈妈挺搞笑的。她总是讲各种故事。之类的事情。我奶奶滑稽极了。我觉得电视。给了我一切。你知道我的意思吗？我总是试图模仿。
Different characters on TV Like, I would watch Bonanza Right? Like, that was one of my shows, Bonanza And that's not necessarily a funny show In Little House on a Pray But I was like, okay I'm gonna use this
电视里的不同角色。比如，我会看《大篷车》。对吧？那是我的节目之一，《大篷车》。那不一定是一部搞笑的剧。在《草原小屋》里也是。但我想，好吧。我要用这个。
Because when I started going to these schools I had white kids in it I'm like, I gotta use this This is their history So I gotta use this So I started wearing This is their history Cowboy vest with tassels on it
因为当我开始去这些学校时。里面有很多白人小孩。我想，我得用这个。这是他们的历史。所以我必须用这个。所以我开始穿……这是他们的历史。带有流苏的牛仔背心。
And I'd be like, hello, partner Howdy, partner Like, they'd be like laughing Like, it's so silly, Tiffany I wear like a bonnet You know, a bonnet Like for Little House on a Pray That you tie around
然后我会说，哈喽，搭档。你好，搭档。就像……他们会哈哈大笑。太傻了，蒂凡尼。我戴着一顶软帽。你知道的，那种软帽。就像《草原小屋》里那种。你要把它系在下巴上。
And I'd be like, hello, hello Hey, come help me Call me Lord Ingos Like, you can even laugh And we will be right back And now, back to the show Jason was on Little House on a Pray When he was a kid, true story
然后我会说，哈喽，哈喽。嘿，来帮帮我。叫我因戈斯勋爵。你看，你们甚至都可以笑。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。杰森小时候演过《草原小屋》，千真万确。
I know So you were actually telling his sister But I love also that you You're like, all the white kids Their existence is They all grew up in like, you know Like the 1800s Yeah
我知道。所以你其实是在给他的妹妹讲。但我也喜欢你这一点。你就像是，所有白人小孩。他们的生存环境是……他们全都在那种地方长大。就像1800年代一样。对。
The poor strong carriages Here goes my thing I thought all white people lived in TV I thought everybody white that I saw Comes from some TV show, some program So that's all I saw, right? And then I'm in a community Where it's just black and some Hispanic
那些破旧结实的马车。这就是我的观点。我以为所有白人都住在电视里。我以为我看到的每个白人。都来自某个电视节目，某种栏目。所以这就是我所看到的一切，对吧？然后我身处一个社区。
When the police would come I thought they were all from chips I'm like, oh man, can I get your autograph? I used to watch chips every day They all had the freaking mustaches And Miami Vice, the detective Come to the house looking for my auntie And I'm like, can I have your autograph, man?
那里只有黑人和一些西班牙裔。当警察来的时候。我以为他们都来自《加州公路巡警》。我心想，哦，天呐，能给我签个名吗？我以前天天看《加州公路巡警》。他们都留着该死的小胡子。还有《迈阿密风云》，那个侦探。
Was there a black actor, a black show That inspired you when that broke And you were like, oh my god, that's not just TV There are black people in the world, too Well, yeah, well Martin was on TV That shit was funny Family matters Family matters, yeah
来家里找我阿姨。我就想，能给我签个名吗，老兄？有没有哪个黑人演员或黑人节目。当它大火时激励了你。让你觉得，哦，天呐，那不仅仅是电视。世界上也有黑人。
What was the character that Martin played The woman across as Shanae Nae? Shanae Nae Yes, Shanae Nae So funny My aunt, my aunt I just had lunch with Martin The other day I was like, this is so crazy
嗯，对，马丁出演了电视节目。那部剧太搞笑了。《凡人琐事》。《凡人琐事》，对。马丁饰演的角色是什么？那个扮演香奈妮的女人？香奈妮。是的，香奈妮。太搞笑了。我阿姨，我阿姨……我前几天刚和马丁一起吃过午餐。
Because I used to watch every single show Every single movie, every single film And now I'm pitching movie ideas to him For us to work together And he wants to work with me, what? Oh, that's great I was mind blowing By the way, of course he wants to work with you
我当时想，这太疯狂了。因为我以前看他的每一场演出。每一部电影，每一部影片。而现在我正在向他推销电影创意。为了让我们一起合作。而且他想跟我合作，什么？哦，太棒了。
But what I used to say when I was a kid I used to sit and watch Martin and be like One day I'm gonna work with him I don't know how I'm gonna work with him I don't know why he will work with me But I'm gonna work with him in some kind of way But you know what, that's how it works As you know, it's like
这简直让我大开眼界。顺便说一句，他当然想跟你合作。但我小时候常说的是。我以前坐在那里看马丁的节目，心想。总有一天我要和他合作。我不知道我要怎么跟他合作。我不知道他为什么会跟我合作。但我总会以某种方式和他合作的。但你知道吗，这就是它的运作方式。正如你所知，这就好比……
It is that kind of like That dreaming about it And that thinking about like making it happen And just going like, I want this to work out I mean, it's not that easy But you know what I mean And was the attention you got from being funny Did that motivate you to want to be an actor?
就是那种……梦想着它发生。并且思考着如何让它成为现实。然后心里想着，我一定要让它成功。我的意思是，这没那么容易。但你知道我的意思。你因为搞笑而获得的关注。有没有激发你想成为演员的愿望？
No, what motivated me to want to be an actor Is this boy, he was in drama We was going to this predominantly white school It was 3% black And he was the only black boy in drama And I was like, oh, if I get in drama Then we gonna have to kiss They gonna have to put us together
不，激发我想成为演员的愿望是……这个男孩，他在戏剧社。我们要去一所主要是白人的学校。那里只有3%的黑人。他是戏剧社里唯一的黑人男孩。然后我想，哦，如果我进了戏剧社。
So I got in drama And turns out I was really good at it Right And Did you get to kiss him? No, because my damn teacher was all liberal And open minded She believed the interracial couples
那我们俩就必须得接吻了。他们必须把我们安排在一起。所以我加入了戏剧社。结果证明我真的很擅长这个。对。你真的亲到他了吗？
So I never got to kiss him I was so mad at her Like, come on Miss Young You got stuck with the white guys But where is it? What the racism not working for me today Oh, she made me sick But then we went into high school
没有，因为我该死的老师太自由主义了。而且思想开放。她相信跨种族情侣。所以我从来没有亲过他。我当时气死她了。拜托，杨老师。你偏偏要安排白人帅哥。
And I followed him into drama in high school Like basically any classes he was doing And whatever he was trying to do That's what I was trying to do And he thought I was just like this silly girl That was always trying to make her laugh But I would save up money And buy him candy grams
但为什么呢？种族主义今天对我不管用了吗？哦，她气死我了。然后我们上了高中。我跟着他进了高中的戏剧社。基本上他选的任何课。无论他尝试做什么。那都是我尝试去做的。
And I make sure he'd like The candy grams usually just have blow pops But I knew he liked Snickers So I made sure there was a snicker in his candy grams I was on it And I would try to write him notes But I spell really bad It was like the worst speller, the worst reader
他以为我只是那种傻里傻气的女孩。总是想逗他笑。但我会存下钱来。给他买糖果卡片。我会确保他喜欢……糖果卡片通常只有棒棒糖。但我知道他喜欢士力架。所以我确保他的糖果卡片里有一块士力架。我可上心了。
So I write him these notes And it would be all misspelled The only thing spelled right is my name What happened to this guy? Do you know where he is now? So he ended up playing for the Washington Redskins But I guess they're called something else now The Washington football team now
我还会试着给他写纸条。但我拼写真的很差。我是拼写最差的，阅读最差的。所以我给他写这些纸条。里面全都是拼写错误的。唯一拼对的就是我的名字。这家伙后来怎么了？你知道他现在在哪儿吗？
Yeah, Washington football team Washington football team Ended up playing for them And went to college and all that stuff And now he does commercial real estate He works for some big commercial real estate company And he has like five kids Are you guys still in touch?
他后来为华盛顿红人队效力。但我想他们现在改叫别的名字了。现在的华盛顿橄榄球队。对，华盛顿橄榄球队。华盛顿橄榄球队。曾为他们效力。去上大学之类的好好经历了这一切。而现在他做商业地产。
He came to my comedy show at the Staples Center And I wrote about him in my book And he showed up with his wife And in my book I talk about like I gave him so much candy He probably doesn't have any teeth anymore And I hadn't seen him in over 20 years He shows up to my comedy show
他在某个大型商业地产公司工作。而且他有大概五个孩子。你们现在还有联系吗？他来斯台普斯中心看了我的脱口秀。我在书里写到了他。他和他的妻子一起出席了。我在书里提到，我以前给他吃太多糖了。
And he has like all brand new teeth Like Hollywood teeth That's my fault That's hilarious But the thing that I loved about him the most Is that his laugh His laugh was like the best laugh in the whole wide world Like I just loved his laugh
他可能已经一颗牙都不剩了。而且我有20多年没见过他了。他竟然出现在我的脱口秀演出现场。而且他换上了一口全新的牙齿。就像好莱坞明星那种牙齿。那是我的错。这太搞笑了。但关于他，我最喜欢的一点是。他的笑声。他的笑声简直是全天下最棒的笑声。我就是超爱他的笑声。
And that's why I wanted to be around him all the time And I used to do whatever it took to make him laugh I would do it Like his laugh just made me When you were doing your show Could you hear him in the audience laughing? No, it was over 7,000 people I couldn't hear
这就是为什么我一直想和他在一起，我以前会想方设法逗他笑，我真的会这么做。他的笑声让我……当你在表演时，你能听到他在观众席里笑吗？不，台下有七千多人，我听不见。
Come on, Jason What do you think she's doing a show for five people? Well, maybe she gave him a good seat Where he was actually up front No, it was over 7,000 people 7,000 people You're talking to Tiffany Haddish, you asshole He did come backstage
拜托，杰森，你觉得她会在只有五个人的地方表演吗？好吧，也许她给他留了个好座位，让他坐在最前面。不，那可是七千多人，七千多人。你在和蒂凡尼·哈迪斯说话，你个混蛋。不过他确实去了后台。
And it was like a high school reunion Everybody I went to school with They had flew in the town and everything Because Tiffany Haddish was at the Staples It was huge And so he came backstage And we had like a party Back there and like
那种感觉就像是一场高中同学聚会。所有和我一起上过学的人都坐飞机赶到了镇上，因为蒂凡尼·哈迪斯在斯台普斯中心演出，场面非常盛大。于是他来到了后台，我们在后台办了个派对，然后……
So all these people I went to school with was there And he was there And I was giving him all the attention And his wife too But I just wanted to hear him laugh And I heard like his laugh Made me feel like a little girl again And made me feel so happy
所有那些和我一起上学的人都在那儿，他也在那儿。我把所有的注意力都给了他，还有他的妻子。但我只是想听他笑，当我听到他的笑声时，那种感觉就像让我回到了小时候，让我感到无比快乐。
Oh, that's so great I love that I wanted to record this I was like, can you laugh into this recorder? He's like, what? I said, never mind That's creepy But I do like that idea
哦，那太棒了，我好喜欢。当时我都想录下来，我问：“你能对着这个录音机笑一下吗？”他问：“什么？”我说：“算了，那挺诡异的。”但我确实很喜欢这个想法。
You guys probably remember too There are certain people in your life Especially or maybe in your family Who you like the way it made you feel When they laugh specifically them Like the sound of their laugh Or the way they laugh Did you guys have people like that in your life?
你们可能也记得，你们生命中的某些人，尤其是或可能是你们的家人，当你听到他们笑时，你会喜欢那种感觉，尤其是他们，就像他们笑的声音，或者他们笑的方式。你们生命中有这样的人吗？
Sean or Jason? I did, yeah I mean, my sisters laugh Tracy, that's Tracy, my sister But wait, Tiffany, did you I think that says a lot about somebody Who keeps in touch with all of those people That you went to high school with
肖恩还是杰森？我有，是的。我是说，我姐姐的笑声。特雷西，那是特雷西，我姐姐。不过等等，蒂凡尼，我觉得这很能说明一个人能和所有那些高中同学保持联系。
And you're still friends with them And that's so great They must just root for you My best friend from junior high She's got one of my favorite laughs too Selena, we've been best friends All these years since we were 12 How about that?
而且你们还是好朋友，这太棒了。他们一定特别支持你。我初中的最好朋友，她的笑声也是我最喜欢的之一。塞莱娜，我们从12岁起就是好朋友，这么多年过去了，觉得怎么样？
They all freak out where you are right now Like in life No, they knew it was going to happen at some point They knew I was going to do something It was like, either you're going to go to jail Or you're going to be famous as well So you're still so connected to where you're from In fact, aren't you opening a
他们对你现在的处境不感到震惊吗？比如在生活方面。不，他们知道这一切迟早会发生。他们知道我会干出点名堂，要么你去坐牢，要么你成名。所以你和你的家乡依然联系紧密，事实上，你是不是在开一个……
Or did you open a supermarket back In the community that you came to? I'm in the process of opening a grocery store If you guys want to be on the board You are more than welcome That's so cool That's really cool Yeah, tell me about that
或者你在你长大的社区里开了一家超市？我正在筹备开一家杂货店，如果你们想加入董事会，非常欢迎。太酷了，真的太酷了。是的，跟我讲讲这个。
I just heard about that from our mutual friend Who told me that you're doing that Yeah, so Which is so great So I'm opening a grocery store Because they're shutting down Like I still live in South Central Los Angeles And the area is transforming
我刚从我们的共同朋友那里听说这件事，他告诉我你在做这个。是的，所以……这太棒了。我要开一家杂货店，因为他们都在关门。就像我依然住在洛杉矶中南部，那个地区正在发生巨变。
It's definitely changing This is probably why I have the blonde hair And I want to fit into my community But they've shut down like three grocery stores Around here Which is really not good And there's no plans of implementing Or putting into
它确实在变。这大概也是我染金发的原因，我想融入我的社区。但他们在这里关了大概三家杂货店，这真的很糟糕，而且也没有任何计划去落实或者建立……
Because of business? Because of poor business? No, because they don't want to pay Five dollars more Right Right They need to pay their employees Five dollars more
是因为生意吗？是因为生意不好吗？不，因为他们不想多付五美元。对，对，他们需要给员工多付五美元。
Because they're essential workers Or whatever And they don't want to do it So they're just shutting down the stores Also, you know, like we were supposed To have a Trader Joe's over here When I bought my house They were saying, oh, the Trader Joe's
因为他们是核心工人什么的，而他们不想这么做，所以他们干脆把店关了。还有，你知道的，就像我们本来应该在这里开一家Trader Joe's的。当我买下这栋房子时，他们说，哦，Trader Joe's……
Is going to open up over here And they didn't open a Trader Joe's And then, you know, in my research Of trying to open In the process of me opening this store I found out that Trader Joe's Only puts themselves in communities That have a high college graduate demographic
要在这里开业了，结果他们根本没开Trader Joe's。然后，你知道的，在我为了开店而做的研究过程中，在我筹备开这家店的过程中，我发现Trader Joe's只把店开在大学毕业生人口比例很高的社区。
Wow So in South Central LA It might not be a lot of college graduates But there are a lot of business owners And people that work with their hands And, you know, service people But they don't want to put a Trader Joe's In this area
哇。所以在洛杉矶中南部，可能没有很多大学毕业生，但有很多企业主、靠双手劳动的人，还有你知道的服务人员，但他们不想在这个区域开Trader Joe's。
So that made me really upset Then the whole thing with Everything that was going on With the injustices and the marching And the protests And I heard the police say We're here to serve the owners We're here to protect the owners
这让我真的很沮丧。然后所有这些事情，那些关于不公正、游行和抗议的事情正在发生，我听到警察说：“我们是来为主人们服务的，我们是来保护主人们的。”
Like that's what we're supposed to do Protect the owners And so that made me really infuriated Then I started reading all these books And I'm reading the color of money And how the other have banks And I'm seeing all the things that have happened And I started doing my research even more
就像那是我们应该做的事情——保护主人们。这让我感到非常愤怒。然后我开始读所有这些书，我读了《金钱的颜色》（The Color of Money）以及其他阶层如何拥有银行，我看到了所有发生的事情，这让我更加深入地进行研究。
And I'm seeing how in a black community It circulates for six hours But in every other community Pretty much every community Besides the black community The dollar circulates for at least 18 hours To 12 days In the Asian community
我看到在黑人社区，金钱只能流通六个小时；但在其他社区，几乎所有社区，除了黑人社区，美元至少流通18小时到12天。在亚裔社区……
12 to 13 days I'm an idiot What does that mean circulates? Circulate means like Okay, so me going to get my hair done And then going to the gas station And then going to the grocery store And then going to like, you know
12到13天。我是个白痴，流通是什么意思？流通的意思是……好吧，比如我去剪头发，然后去加油站，然后去杂货店，然后去……你知道的……
Buy clothing and do activities Like once I go get my hair done That's it There's nothing else that's owned by a black person There's not a lot of places to circulate that money I see Not a lot of like, owned businesses It's what I'm saying
买衣服和进行各种活动。一旦我去剪了头发，就那样了，没有什么是黑人拥有的了。没有多少地方可以让钱流通起来。我懂，没有很多由自己拥有的企业，这就是我想表达的。
It's not a lot of places to circulate That's wild So, like, I don't know if you notice this If you go to Koreatown There's Korean everything There's a Korean grocery store There's Korean bank There's Korean, you know, clothing store
没有多少地方可以让资金流通。这太疯狂了。所以，我不知道你们有没有注意到这一点，如果你去韩国城，到处都是韩国的东西。有韩国杂货店，有韩国银行，有韩国的服装店……
Korean carpenters It's Korean everything When you go to a Mexican part of town There's a Mexican grocery store It's on every corner Little grocery stores Big grocery stores Like, Mexican this, Mexican that
韩国木匠，到处都是韩国的。当你去墨西哥人聚居的城镇时，有墨西哥杂货店，每个街角都有，小杂货店，大杂货店，比如墨西哥这个，墨西哥那个。
Right, even banks When you go to a black community What do you see? Liquor stores run by Asians You see a lot of churches You know And once I get my tides over to the church That's pretty much it
对，甚至还有银行。当你去黑人社区时，你看到了什么？由亚裔经营的酒类专卖店，你看到很多教堂，你知道的。一旦我把十一税交到教堂，也就差不多这样了。
You know You see hair salons Once I get my hair cut or hair done That's it So how are we supposed to maintain Generational wealth How are we supposed to keep people from going to jail Committing crimes
你知道的，你看到美发沙龙，一旦我理了发或做了头发，也就这样了。所以我们怎么维持代际财富？我们怎么阻止人们去坐牢、犯罪……
If there's no opportunity Something else I'm just remembering I saw you somewhere Speak about this I'm going to get it wrong So please correct me You really said the importance about Really thinking about how to
如果没有机会的话。还有一件事我刚刚想起来，我在某个地方看到你谈到过这个，我可能会记错，所以请纠正我。你确实说过关于认真思考如何……
Reach the goal of owning something I thought that was so great Right So that's why I'm opening this grocery store Because I feel like What kind of business holds thousands of businesses In one place Grocery stores
实现拥有某些东西的目标的重要。我觉得那太棒了。对，所以这就是为什么我要开这家杂货店，因为我觉得……什么类型的企业能在同一个地方容纳成千上万的商业？杂货店。
There's a million There's 100,000 companies In a grocery store, right? So if I make sure that 75% of those products In that grocery store come from black vendors Black farmers Which I don't know if you know The disparity that's happening with black farmers
有一百万，杂货店里有十万家公司，对吧？所以如果我确保杂货店里75%的产品来自黑人供应商、黑人农民——我不知道你们是否了解黑人农民正在面临的差距……
When we used to be the main farmers And now we get pushed out of farming So anyways I want to create a place for that synergy to happen Right And then not just It can be a mixture of things Because I know there's not
我们曾经是主要的农民，现在我们却被排挤出了农业。总之，我想创造一个让这种协同效应发生的地方，对吧？而且不仅仅是……它可以是各种事物的结合，因为我知道没有……
There's not enough black owned businesses To fill up the grocery store But have that be a priority And then it's not really a grocery store It's a community center Because I want there to be cooking classes Because they took home economics out of school Which I think is to destroy the families
没有足够的黑人企业来填满整个杂货店，但要把它作为一个优先事项。而且它其实不仅仅是一家杂货店，它是一个社区中心，因为我希望那里有烹饪课程，因为他们把家政课从学校里取消了，我认为那是为了摧毁家庭。
Yeah I think that was to destroy the family structure Because if you can't feed your family If you can't maintain the bills And all this stuff That's what home economics teaches you how to do Then you The family falls apart
对，我认为那是为了摧毁家庭结构。因为如果你无法养家糊口，如果你无法支付账单和所有这些费用——家政课教的就是如何做到这些——那么你……家庭就会破裂。
When the family falls apart The community falls apart When the community falls apart People are getting shot and killed There's crime happening Because families are root of everything So I want to teach financial literacy As well
当家庭破裂时，社区就会破裂；当社区破裂时，人们就会遭到枪击和杀害，犯罪就会发生，因为家庭是一切的根源。所以我也想教导金融素养。
So once you have People that know how to Understand money And how it works And you have people that are eating better Which is going to help with the mental health Right Jason
所以一旦你有了……人们懂得理解金钱及其运作方式，并且人们吃得更好，这有助于心理健康，对吧，杰森？
And they're able to cook for themselves And sense of pride Right Then they'll be stronger When they're stronger Their family is stronger When the family is stronger The community is stronger
他们能够自己做饭，并产生自豪感，对吧？然后他们会变得更强大。当他们更强大时，他们的家庭就会更强大；当家庭更强大时，社区就会更强大。
And less need for violence That's This is fantastic How do I I want to get involved in that You're more than welcome to come You got my number, Sean I do, girl
暴力需求就会减少。这……这太棒了。我怎么……我想参与其中。非常欢迎你来，你有我的电话，肖恩。我有，姑娘。
Call me I'll put you on my board Count me and Will in as well We just had someone on the show LeBron James Who's very, very involved With community and family And all that stuff too
给我打电话，把我加到你的董事会上。把我和威尔也算进去。我们节目刚才刚来过一个人——勒布朗·詹姆斯，他非常非常积极地参与社区、家庭和所有这些事情。
I bet you he'd lend a helping hand As well Especially in Los Angeles Well, I'm definitely My next step is to reach out To a lot of the athletes But Kevin's on my board Lil' Ralph Hallory's on my board
我敢打赌他也会伸出援手，尤其是在洛杉矶。嗯，我接下来的一步绝对是联系许多运动员，但凯文在我的董事会上，小拉尔夫·霍利（Lil' Ralph Hallory）在我的董事会上……
Jada Pinkett Smith Snoop We got people from the community But I need your help too Listen, count us in Anything I can do Count all three of us in Tiffany, you're incredible
贾达·萍克特·史密斯、史努比（Snoop），我们有来自社区的人，但我也需要你的帮助。听着，算上我们。我能做任何事，把我们三个都算上。蒂凡尼，你太不可思议了。
I love Yeah, it's so motivating You're such a self-starter And there's nothing that holds you back You're just like This is a problem Let's go to the root of the problem Let's do it
我喜欢……是的，这太励志了。你是一个天生的实干家，没有什么能阻挡你。你就像是：这是一个问题，让我们直奔问题根源，干吧。
And I think you I feel like you're like that In every aspect of your life You make shit happen I'm a visionary I'm a visionary And then I try to pull the people together To help me make this thing happen
而且我觉得你……我觉得你在生活的各个方面都是这样，你能把事情办成。我是个有远见的人，我是个有远见的人。然后我试着把大家聚在一起，帮我把这件事实现。
I love it I've been sitting with City Council Like sitting with the City Council members Been sitting with the City Supervisors And I've come up with like two locations That I think are great I got to figure out how much it's going to cost That's the part
我太喜欢了。我一直和市议会坐在一起开会，一直和市议员们坐在一起，一直和市监察员们坐在一起。我想出了两个我认为很棒的地点，我得算算需要多少钱，这才是关键部分。
I faved up all this money Literally Because the government Be trying to take all your money Right So I figured out a way to put The money to the side For the community
我存了所有的钱，字面意义上的，因为政府总是试图拿走你所有的钱，对吧？所以我找到了一个把钱存起来留给社区的方法。
So like And it's like tax-free And it's for the community This is where Panama comes in This is Panama This is old Panama Have you considered money, Carlo? And the Cayman Islands as well
所以就像……而且是免税的，是留给社区的。这就是摩纳哥（Panama）切入的时候了。这是摩纳哥，这是老摩纳哥。你考虑过金钱吗，卡洛？还有开曼群岛。
You just need a big duffel bag I've been to the Cayman Islands Not interested Haven't been to Monte Carlo But I will check it out The Monaco is incredible for banking So what does your vision look like For ten years from now?
你只需要一个大旅行袋。我去过开曼群岛，没兴趣。没去过蒙特卡洛，但我会去看看。摩纳哥对于银行业务来说太不可思议了。那么，你对十年后的远景有什么样的设想？
Because your ascension has been incredible I even have a whole book Okay This is how hard I've been working on it I have a whole book phone What it would be For the co-op Yes, for the co-op
因为你的崛起太不可思议了。我甚至有一整本书。好吧，这就是我为之付出了多少努力。我有一整本电话簿，写着关于合作社……是的，关于合作社……
For the grocery store So what's the ratio that you would love to see Between your philanthropy And your career And your life with common And all kinds of things Like, is there... Are you the kind of person that has a firm vision
关于杂货店的设想。那么，在你的慈善事业、你的职业生涯以及你与康姆（Common）的生活以及各种事情之间，你希望看到的比例是什么？有没有……你是那种对未来一年、五年、十年的样子有坚定愿景，并以此指导自己的人吗？
Of what the next year, five, ten years looks like And that's what guides you? Yeah, I have a plan I have a plan But I don't know Of course you do But it's God's plan, right? I have an idea of what I want
是的，我有一个计划。我有一个计划，但我不知道……你当然有。但这是上帝的计划，对吧？我对自己想要什么有个概念。
But whatever God has in store That's what's going to happen, right? But I have it all written out Like, you know, in my mind I'm going to open a grocery store Up in two to three years It'll open I have Discovery Plus
但无论上帝有什么安排，那才是将要发生的事，对吧？但我把它都写下来了，就像，你知道的，我心里想的是我将在两到三年内开一家杂货店，它会开业的。我有Discovery+频道……
Following me around Recording all of it Because, you know In my community, a lot of people are like Why don't Oprah come back And open up a bank? Why don't they... These people get all famous
跟着我到处跑，把这一切都记录下来，因为，你知道的，在我的社区里，很多人都在问：为什么奥普拉不回来开一家银行？为什么他们……这些人变得很有名，却不在社区里做任何事？这就好比，如果你没有得到适当的帮助，如果你不愿意和朋友交谈并寻求帮助，问问“你认识谁能帮我把这事办成”……这就真的很困难。
And they don't do anything in the community And it's like, it's really difficult If you don't have the proper help If you're not willing to like Talk to your friends And ask for help And be like, who do you know That can help me get this done
而且他们对社区没有任何贡献。这就好比，如果没有适当的帮助，如果你不愿意和朋友沟通、寻求帮助，并且问问“你认识谁能帮我搞定这件事”，那真的会非常困难。
Like, if you're not willing to do that Put yourself out there like that It's very difficult to do Right So I've been putting myself out there And trying So in my mind The store opened in two years
比如，如果你不愿意那样做 把自己那样展现出来 这其实很难，对吧 所以我一直在把自己展现出来 并在努力 所以在我的想象中 这家店两年后就会开业
Maybe three And then I'll open them up All over the country And in ten years They'll be in every Underserved community all over That's so exciting And then people will have
也许三年后 然后我会把店开遍 全国各地 十年之内 它们会出现在全国每一个 资源匮乏的社区 这太令人兴奋了 然后人们会拥有
More home ownership America will be great America will be great again Because they'll be more Secure people mentally, physically And financially Yeah, I love that Look at you go
更多的房屋所有权 美国会变得伟大 美国会再次伟大 因为人们会在精神、身体 和财务上 更加有安全感 是啊，我太喜欢这样了 瞧你这干劲
Are you in common going to get married Or are you going to remain Just common law partners I have no idea Well, first of all We're not necessarily common law Because we don't live In the same house
你们俩打算结婚吗 还是打算一直做 普通法伴侣？ 我根本不知道 嗯，首先 咱们不一定是普通法夫妻 因为我们不住在 同一个房子里
Oh, that's true I would love for him To always be my friend If he decides he wants to marry me Who he gonna have to... I don't want to ring I want an apartment building You know what I mean
哦，也是 我倒是希望他 能永远做我的朋友 如果他哪天决定想娶我 他得…… 我不想要戒指 我想要一栋公寓楼 你懂我意思吗
I can know how they'd like Present you with a ring I don't want him to present me With the deed to a duplex Or a 36plex Present me with an apartment building Because then... Does he know this?
我能理解他们怎么会 想送你一枚戒指 我才不要他送我 一栋复式公寓的房契 或是三十六联排公寓的房契 送我一栋公寓楼吧 因为这样…… 他知道这事吗？
Yes, he's aware He said I'm crazy for that I said no, I'm not crazy I'm smart because a marriage Is a union of two businesses And the whole point of coming together Is to grow yourselves But also grow a family
知道，他清楚 他说我这么想太疯狂了 我说不，我一点也不疯狂 我很聪明，因为婚姻 本质上是两个商业实体的结合 在一起的核心目的 是为了共同成长 同时也要组建家庭
And make sure they have something To inherit So this ring They can inherit the ring But that ain't... What's that? Two thousand, three thousand Maybe ten thousand dollars
还要确保他们有东西 可以继承 所以这枚戒指 他们顶多继承个戒指 但那算什么…… 那是多少？两千、三千 也许一万美元
What is that? But if you get an apartment building That will increase in value The children will always be able To go to school We'll always have something If we get sick or something We'll have something to cash out
那算什么？ 但如果你买下一栋公寓楼 那会不断升值 孩子们总能有钱上学 我们总能有点积底 如果我们生病或者出点什么事 我们就会有能变现的东西
And be able to take care of ourselves There'll be something there for us God bless you That's what I want That's great, I love that Come at me with a deed, baby Don't come at me with a ring Yeah, put a deed on it
还能照顾好我们自己 这样我们就有保障了 天佑你也 这才是我想要的 太棒了，我太喜欢这样了 拿着房契来找我吧，宝贝 别拿什么戒指来找我 是的，拿房契来定情吧
Because if you're trying to buy my life And change my last name To your last name His name's so common The ring ain't gonna do it We can get the ring after you get the building You're lucky he doesn't have a last name I mean, that's the good part
因为如果你想买下我的人生 把我的姓氏 改成你的姓氏 他的姓氏太大众化了 戒指可不管用 等你买了楼，我们再谈戒指 幸亏他没有姓氏 我的意思是，这倒挺好
He does have a last name Oh, he does, I know It's O-N No It's Lynn All right, back to the show You seem to have it all figured out I don't have it all figured out
他有姓氏啊 哦，他有，我知道 是 O-N 额 不是 是 Lynn 好吧，言归正传 你好像把一切都安排得明明白白 我可没有把一切都安排得明明白白
I'm just... No, you got it all figured out Having a plan is seventy-five percent Of the way there So you and Kevin have known each other At Kevin Hart I've known Kevin for a long time, too For twenty years or something
我只是…… 不，你全都规划好了 有计划就等于成功了百分之七十五 所以你和凯文认识很久了吗 指凯文·哈特 我认识凯文也很久了 大概有二十年了吧
I met him, he was doing a pilot With my ex-wife years ago Such a good guy Yeah, I agree Such a great dude How big of a part did Kevin play In your life when you were starting out? Well, in the first beginnings
我刚认识他时，他多年前正和我的前妻 一起拍试播集 真是个好人 是的，我同意 真是个绝佳的家伙 凯文在你刚出道时 在你生命中扮演了多大的角色？ 嗯，在刚开始的时候
Like I started in ninety-seven So in the first beginnings, not much But me and Kevin, we met like 2004, 2005 And he's been like a big brother to me Ever since Giving me great advice, guidance When I was homeless
比如我是97年开始的 所以刚开始时，关系不大 但我和凯文大约在2004、2005年认识的 他一直像个大哥哥一样 对我关爱有加 从那以后 给了我很多极好的建议和指导 在我无家可归的时候
He gave me a few hundred dollars To get a place to stay Hold on He was like, stay in a hotel For a week and I'm like Let's pause there When were you homeless? Walk us through that
他给了我几百块钱 让我能找个地方住 等等 他说去住一周酒店 然后我说 我们暂停一下 你什么时候无家可归的？ 给我们讲讲那段经历吧
Three different times The first time is when I was emancipated From foster care I was homeless The next time is when When me and my auntie were sharing an apartment And then we basically got evicted Because they were selling the apartment
有过三次 第一次是我从寄养家庭 解除监护关系之后 我就无家可归了 下一次是啥时候 当我和我阿姨合租一套公寓时 然后我们基本上被赶出来了 因为房东要把公寓卖掉
And there was no money You know how when they ask you to leave They give you like your deposit back And all that What they were taking forever to give that back So my auntie moved in with her dude I moved into my car I got into my car
而且当时没钱 你知道的，当他们让你搬走时 会把押金什么的退给你 结果他们退钱磨磨蹭蹭的 所以我阿姨搬去跟她的男友一起住了 我搬进了我的车里 我上了车
And so I was like sitting in front of It was crazy because I was like Sitting in front of the department Children services office Because I found out they had An independent living program For emancipated foster youth And so an independent living program
然后我就坐在…… 太疯狂了，我就坐在 那个儿童服务部门办公室的门前 因为我听说他们为 解除寄养关系的青年 设立了独立生活项目 所以所谓的独立生活项目
They teach you how to pay your bills How to pay rent How to you know Fill out applications How to apply for jobs And all this stuff And I already had a job I just didn't have a place to stay
他们会教你如何付账单 如何付房租 如何去，你知道的 填写申请表 如何申请工作 以及诸如此类的事情 我当时其实已经有工作了 只是没有地方住
So I was getting on these social workers' nerves too Two weeks I was in their office Every day washing my ass Sitting in their lobby Go to work Come back Sleep in front of their building in my car And then finally they gave me an apartment
所以我当时也把这些社工给烦透了 我在他们办公室待了两周 天天在那儿洗屁股 坐在他们的前厅里 去上班 回来 睡在他们大楼门前的车里 最后他们终于给我分了一套公寓
And things worked out great But then I was emancipated from that You know you could only be there for so long And they gave me my money to move But Things didn't just didn't just didn't pan out They didn't pan My credit wasn't good enough
事情进展得很顺利 但后来我的那段资助期也结束了 你知道的，你在那里只能住一段时间 他们给了我搬家的钱 但 事情就是不顺利、不顺利、不顺利 进展不顺 我的信用不够好
A lot of things wasn't good I didn't understand the power of credit I didn't understand It was a lot of things I didn't know Because I didn't have a mother or a father Or anybody teaching me about like certain things So it was very difficult right It's incredible the way that you figured
很多条件都不够好 我当时不懂信用的力量 我不懂 有很多事情我当时都不知道 因为我没有妈妈或爸爸 也没有人教我关于某些事情的知识 所以当时真的很艰难，对吧 你能把事情全盘理清
Everything out and you put You put everything in front of you And you knocked it down It's just it's really stunning I mean good for you So I would go do these comedy shows I would go do these comedy shows I'm at the Laugh Factory
并且把一切 都安排妥当 最后还克服了困难 这真的太不可思议了 我是说，真为你高兴 所以我会去演这些喜剧秀 我会去演这些喜剧秀 我去“笑声工厂”
And that's where I would get to eat Right and that's where I get to be around people And I would just I would just try to be as happy As possible right Just as much joy as possible And it was so crazy because Kevin Like I had all my stuff in the car And Kevin pulled up behind me one day
那就是我能吃上饭的地方 对，那也是我能融入人群的地方 我就会 尽量让自己保持快乐 越快乐越好 真的太疯狂了，因为有一天 凯文——我当时所有的东西都在车里——凯文把车停在我车后面
And I would show up like 10, 15 minutes late Like I'd be down the street but I would wake So nobody could see all the shit in my car And Kevin pulled up behind me He saw it all and he was like What's going on with you? And I was like nothing, nothing He was like what's all that in your car?
我通常会迟到10、15分钟 我其实就在街区那头，但我在等候 这样就没人能看到我车里的那一堆破烂了 凯文把车停在我后面 他把这一切都看在眼里，然后问我 你怎么回事？我说没事，没事 他问车里那一堆是什么
I'm just in between places I'm moving right now And at this point I'm sleeping in front of like These houses and Beverly Hills You know just in like washing up my job And just you know trying to And always make sure my hair was done And my nails were done
我只是在两处住所之间过渡 我现在正在搬家 那个时候，我其实是睡在 像比弗利山庄那些房子前面的街上 你知道的，就在上班的地方洗漱 然后，你知道的，努力保持 并且确保我的头发弄好 我的指甲也做好
Because I figured if my hair and nails are always done Nobody will know you know And I keep baby wipes always smell good Like nobody will know But me but Kevin figured it out At a conversation with me He's like write out a list of goals He's like I want you to get
因为我想象着，只要我的头发和指甲总是弄好 就没人会看出来，你知道的 而且我随身带着婴儿湿巾，总能保持清爽 没人会看出来的 只有我自己知道，但凯文还是看出来了 他跟我聊了聊 让我写下一张目标清单
Here's a few hundred dollars Write out a list of goals He starts doing one thing every day Towards that goal You can do at least one thing Every day towards the goal You'll accomplish it I talk to, I go to
他说，我给你几百块钱 写下一张目标清单 他开始每天朝着这个目标 去做一件事 你只要每天至少为这个目标 做一件事 你就能实现它 我跟别人说，我去
I have a scholarship set up In my alma mater Illinois State University And when I go down there And talk to the kids It's the first thing I say I always talk about writing out your goals And exactly everything you're saying It's so true
我在我的母校 伊利诺伊州立大学 设立了一笔奖学金 每当我回母校 和孩子们交流时 这是我说的第一句话 我总是谈到写下你的目标 就像你刚才说的那些完全一样 这千真万确
That's the first step You got to see it If you see it It becomes infectious Wow Tiffany that's incredible Tiffany it's so incredible Like you go from this thing And talking about you know
那是第一步 你必须看见它 如果你看见了 它就会产生感染力 哇，蒂芬妮，这太不可思议了 蒂芬妮，这真的太不可思议了 就像你从那段经历走过来 谈到那些事
Even just now when you're talking about it Obviously it's very emotional About being in that place Where I mean real struggle Really real struggle And then your day And then what you're going to do Is you're going at night
甚至就在刚才，当你谈起这些时 显然情绪非常激动 谈到曾经身处那种境地 我的意思是，那真的是真正的挣扎 极其真实的挣扎 然后你白天经历这些 紧接着你要做的是 到了晚上
And you're making people laugh Out of your own struggle The flip of it is You're going and making people laugh There's something sort of So bigger than all of us in that There's something really really powerful About that
你要去逗笑人们 用你自己的挣扎作为素材 而这一切的反转在于 你去逗笑别人 这其中有一种 某种比我们所有人都更伟大的东西 这里面有着某种 非常非常强大力量
That you were able to go and do that Because I know for me I would feel such a sense of give up Like fuck I want to be able to do it And to hear how Not only are you able to get it But that was my drug It's still my drug
你能去做到这些 因为我知道如果是我的话 我会产生一种想要放弃的感觉 F***的，我才想做到呢 听到你不仅能够做到 还能把它变成—— 那是我的毒品 这至今仍是我的毒品
It's the laughter It's my drug I get that I mean yeah I needed it to even be able to sleep To even be able to feel okay About like anything What was the one moment though
欢笑就是我的毒品 我懂我的意思是，是的 我需要它，甚至才能入睡 甚至才能对任何事情 感觉好一点 不过，在经历了这一切
Through all of that And all of that pain and that struggle What was that one What was the first glimmer of light What was the first moment you were like Wait a minute I think this might be the gate out of here Kevin caring
以及所有的痛苦和挣扎之后 那个时刻是什么？ 第一道曙光是什么？ 你觉得“等等，这可能是条出路”的那个瞬间是什么？ 是凯文的关心
Somebody actually caring In like trying to help Then Paul Mooney found out And Paul Mooney's like I heard you was homeless You need to get your You need a place to stay My sister
有人真的在乎 并试图提供帮助 然后保罗·穆尼发现了 保罗·穆尼说 我听说你无家可归了 你需要把你的……你需要个住处 我妹
She got kids She need a nanny You could go stay over there And take care of her kids I'm like I'd much rather be homeless Than be a nanny But no wonder you're so focused
她有孩子 她需要个保姆 你可以去那儿住 顺便照顾她的孩子 我心想 我宁愿无家可归 也不去当保姆 难怪你这么专注
On giving back And providing some hope And some guidance And some advice to folks That might be right where you were X number of years ago And just even just letting them know That it's possible
于回馈社会 并为那些 可能正处于你当年那种境地的人 提供一些希望、指导 和建议 哪怕只是让他们知道 这并非不可能
And here was my path Good for you So inspiring It's so inspiring I mean it's a long ass road It's a long long journey Jason you wouldn't have been able To go live in your car Jason right
这就是我走过的路 为你高兴 太励志了 太励志了 这真是一条漫长得要命的路 这是一段漫长而艰辛的旅程 杰森，你肯定没法 去睡在你的车里吧，杰森 对吧
Because the Porsche is so small In those days Like you would have But I had a Geometro bro I was in a two hour hatchback Geometro You can live in anything If you want to live
因为保时捷太小了 当年那种情况下 你本来可以的 但我开的是一辆几何汽车，兄弟 我开的是一辆两门掀背的几何汽车 只要你想活下去 你住在什么里面都可以
My God It's so inspiring It makes me It is inspiring It is incredible You're such a force I will say again When we first got to know each other
天哪 太励志了 这让我—— 这确实很励志 简直不可思议 你真是一股强大的力量 我还是要说 当我们刚开始了解彼此的时候
And Tiffy You don't have kids though Do you want kids? I don't have any kids I do want to adopt I don't know if I'm even Physically capable Of actually giving birth
蒂菲，你其实没有孩子吧 你想要孩子吗？ 我没有孩子 我确实想领养 我不知道我自己在生理上 是否具备生育能力
You know that's on God But definitely I want to adopt Because I wish somebody Would have adopted me And taught me Like a better way So I want to do that For somebody else
你知道，这得看上帝的安排 但我绝对想领养 因为我多么希望当年 有人能领养我 并教给我 一条更好的路 所以我想为别人 弥补这个遗憾
Everything I wish would have Happened for me Is what I'm trying to give To others You know that's what I'm trying To do for somebody else That's so That's just
所有我希望曾经 发生在我身上的事 正是我现在试图给予 别人的事 你知道的，这就是我想要 为别人做的事 太……这简直是
That's such a basic Sort of You know some people We all sort of grow up With a certain level of You know pluses and minuses And all of our situations And every kid has a choice
这是一种非常基本的 某种，你知道的，我们所有人成长过程中 都带有一定程度的 各种生活中的加分项和减分项 每个孩子都有一个选择
To whether We're going to take And learn from it Or sort of spend their life You know everyone's Going to pay the bill now You know but taking it And sort of seeing
是去接受 并从中汲取教训 还是把一生都用来，你知道的，每个人现在都要为之买单，你知道的 而是去接受它 并看到
Well this is the opposite Of what I want And I'm going to do The positive side of it The different side of it It's just such a generous And a lovely way to Approach life
好吧，这正是我所不想要的 我要去做积极的一面 走向不同的另一面 这种对待生活的方式 真的非常慷慨 也非常可爱
With such a healthier Perspective I literally just wrote down What you said Who me? No not me No what Tiffy just said Everything I wish happened
带着如此健康的 视角 我刚刚把你刚才说的话记下来了 谁？我？ 不，不是我 不，蒂菲刚才说的那句 我希望发生在我身上的一切
To me is what I want To get back to others I love that Yeah Would you rather Your entire year be spent On stage doing stand up Or do you love being on sets
正是我想要回馈给别人的 我太喜欢这句话了 是的 你是愿意把一整年的时间 都花在舞台上说单口喜剧 还是更喜欢泡在片场
In that whole process Because it's a wildly Different thing On stage On stage much more fun On stage because it's Immediate gratification Right
在整个过程中 因为这是一件完全不同的事 在舞台上 在舞台上好玩得多 在舞台上是因为它是即时的满足感 对吧
Immediate Unless it's like a Super dope ass crew Like if the crew's Really dope And we like have A really great time together Which like that was girls' trip
即时 除非是那种超级棒的剧组 比如剧组真的很棒 然后我们在一起度过了非常美好的时光 就像《闺蜜假期》那样
We would have so much fun together And they'd be like Cut and we're all laughing And they'd be like I can't believe you just did that Like if it's that thing Then great but on stage is Well you're now in a position
我们在一起玩得太开心了 他们会说“咔”，然后我们都在笑 他们会说“真不敢相信你刚才那样做” 如果是那种情况 那当然很好 但在舞台上呢 嗯，你现在处于这样一个位置
To any set that you're on You can control the Or certainly influence the The vibe, the atmosphere The harmony on that set You can set an example And basically say Let's not all take ourselves seriously
在你所在的任何片场 你都可以控制 或者说至少能影响片场的氛围、气氛 和谐的关系 你可以树立一个榜样 基本上就是说 咱们别太把自个儿当回事了
And let's have fun out here Yeah and we always have fun And no matter what set I'm on We have a good time I always have a good time Even if I'm like Feeling sick or something I'll be like everybody
咱们在这儿玩得开心点 是的，我们总是玩得很开心 无论我在哪个片场 我们都过得很愉快 我总是过得很愉快 即使我感觉有点生病什么的 我也会对大家说
I don't feel that best today So I might be a little bit Out of character But just work with me But I feel like I'm turning into the devil himself Okay But we gonna work with him
我今天感觉不太好 所以我可能有点反常 但请大家多担待 感觉我快变成恶魔本尊了 好吧 但我们会配合他的
In action Hey guys One day we were doing press And you were really sick Remember you were really sick And then we went over to England And you were so tired But she wouldn't take a day off
开拍 嘿，伙计们 有一天我们在做宣传 你病得真的很重 记得吗，你病得很重 然后我们去了英国 你累得要命 但她就是不肯休息一天
You were like doing shows And you were doing the thing And then you flew to England You were like sick But you could not tell Once they were rolling You were like You were in it
你一直在做节目 你在做着该做的事 然后你飞去了英国 你当时病了 但你完全看不出来 一旦开始拍摄 你就进入状态了
In action Yeah Wait tip you have a show tonight This afternoon This afternoon Oh my god I wanna see you do One of those big huge venue shows
你完全投入进去了 等下，蒂芙尼，你今晚有一场演出 下午 这场下午的演出 哦天哪，我想看你做 这种大型体育馆级别的演出
Cause I feel like that used to happen A lot more when I was a little kid Like you know the George Carlins Or the Richard Priers Or Eddie Murphy's Or those big shows Robin Williams do them
因为我觉得这在我小时候经常发生 比如说，你知道的乔治·卡林 或者理查德·普赖尔 或者埃迪·墨菲 或者那些大型演出 罗宾·威廉姆斯也做过
Right Do we have many of those anymore I mean I guess we do right Netflix does tons of those Yeah You should look on the internet dude I do tons of them Like I go on tour
对吧 咱们现在还有很多这种演出吗？我的意思是，我想是有的吧，网飞做了很多这种演出 对吧 嘿，你应该上网查查，老兄 我做了很多这种演出 就像我去巡演
And it's like just theaters I do theaters Like you know 4,000, 5,000 seat theaters And do you walk around each day With like a little pad of paper In your back pocket And when you see Or think of something funny
全都是剧院 我在剧院演出 比如说你知道的，四千、五千个座位的剧院 你每天随身带着 一个小记事本 放在后裤兜里 当你看到 或想到什么有趣的事情
You jot it down Or is your mind Can you just like Remember that stuff I voice record I voice record it Yeah On my phone
你把它记下来 还是说你的大脑 能够直接记住那些东西 我会用语音记录 我会用语音备忘录记录 是的 存在手机里
I also like If somebody ever got a hold of my phone And listened to Or my voice memo They would be like What the That's what she thinking I would kill to hear that
我还觉得 如果有人拿到我的手机 听了我的语音备忘录 他们会想 “什么鬼，她脑子里在想这个” 我简直做梦都想听听那个
I would love to hear that Like it's some crazy stuff And then what's your process after that I'll call my friends And talk about it Oh so you'll talk to your friends about it But then will you write it down And actually try to structure it
我太想听听看了 感觉全都是些疯狂的东西 然后你之后的流程是什么？ 我会给朋友们打电话 聊聊这个 哦，所以你会跟朋友们聊起这个 但你还会把它写下来 并且真正试着去构建它
In some sort of like How much do you rely on Kind of the written word Or will you just kind of Freestyle it And just kind of have a concept If I feel like it's a big concept A big idea
用某种……你有多大程度上依赖 这种写下来的文字 还是说你会即兴发挥 只有一个概念 如果我觉得这是一个宏大的概念 一个宏大的主意
I will sit down in my notebook And I'll write it down Usually Right before I go to bed I'll listen to All the voice memos That I've done And I'll write down
我会坐在笔记本前 把它写下来 通常就在我睡觉前我会听完 我做过的所有语音备忘录 然后我会写下
The biggest ideas Right And the biggest ideas I'll like put little Like a Remember how in school Used to do the The thought bubble
最棒的想法 对吧 最棒的想法我会画上小小的 就像 记得你在学校里 经常画的那种 思想泡泡吗
And then all the little Bubbles all around it Right So And I'll do that Like little bubbles all around Like little punch lines Potential funny things
然后周围全是小泡泡 对吧 所以我会那样做 周围全是小泡泡 就像小妙语、潜在的趣事
How would I tell this As a story And then I let it go And I stick it under my pillow And I go to sleep Right And I imagine it's happening
我要怎么把这个 讲成一个故事 然后我就不管它了 把它塞在枕头底下 然后睡觉 对吧 我想象着它正在
In my brain As I'm sleeping I love that Is that a process That someone taught you Or is that you created Your own way To do it that way
我的脑海里发生着 在我睡觉的时候 我太喜欢这个了 这是别人教你的方法 还是你自己摸索出来的 一套这样做的方法
I'm kind of just doing that In comedy camp When I went to the Laugh Factory comedy camp They would teach us Like If you have a punch line The thing that's funny
我其实就是这么做的 在喜剧训练营 当我去“笑声工厂”喜剧训练营时 他们会教我们 比如说 如果你有一个妙语 好笑的点
You write that down And then You write it out as a story Then write it out as a story And how do you get to that punch line But always go with the story Like the stories are the best things The best comedians tell a story
你把它写下来 然后 你把它写成一个故事 接着把它写成一个故事 以及你是如何得出那个妙语的 但永远要以故事为主 故事才是最棒的东西 最棒的喜剧演员都在讲故事
And it's filled up with punches Right And your laughs per minute You want You know, you want to Depends on you as a person Do you want 30 laughs per minute You want
而且里面充满了爆梗 对吧 至于你每分钟的笑声数 你希望 你知道的，你希望取决于你个人 你想要每分钟30个笑声吗 你想要
So like every two seconds Somebody's laughing Or do you want You know 5 or 10 or 15 laughs per minute Depends on the Design of the story though Right
所以就像每隔两秒钟 有人在笑 还是你想要 比如说每分钟5个、10个或15个笑声 这取决于 故事的构思 对吧
Like how do you want it And how physical is the comedy Then I start watching a lot of Like Jerry Lewis and Charlie Chaplin And all these Because they were resonating All over the world Well, how do you resonate
比如你希望它是怎样的 喜剧的肢体动作有多少 然后我开始大量观看 杰瑞·刘易斯和查理·卓别林 以及所有这些人的表演 因为他们在全世界 都能引起共鸣 那么，你该如何在
All over the world If you don't speak The languages of All over the world Physical You got to use your instrument You got to use your body You got to have
全世界引起共鸣 如果你不会说 全世界的语言 靠肢体 你必须运用你的乐器 你必须运用你的身体 你必须拥有
In the tone of your voice The way that you talk And the way you squint your face It's like People understand that No matter what Yeah No matter what they speak
你的语调 你说话的方式 以及你眯起眼睛的方式 就像 人们能理解这一点 无论如何 是的 无论他们说的是什么语言
They feel They know energy Right So make sure your energy's on And you can Like And learn how to gauge that With the words
他们能感受到 他们能感知到能量 对吧 所以要确保你的能量在线 并且你可以 比如 学习如何用语言去衡量这一点
You seem to have Sean, do you think you'll ever get Above zero laughs per minute No I'm Look, if I get one If I get one No, that'd be so good
你似乎有肖恩，你觉得你这辈子能做到 每分钟笑声大于零吗 不，我……你看，如果我能得到一个 如果我能得到一个 不，那可太棒了
Right, if you got one That'd be so good I go for one every like Four or five hours Yeah You're crushing it But Tiffany You seem to have like
对吧，如果你能得到一个 那可太棒了 我大概每四五个小时才有一个笑声 是啊，你太牛了 但蒂芙尼 你似乎拥有
Endless, bountiful energy Yeah And And positivity And Oh no, I'm an asshole First thing in the morning Yeah
无尽的、充沛的能量 是啊 还有 积极性 还有 哦不，一大早我就是个混蛋 对吧
Piece of shit Yeah, but who is it? Piece of shit after my cold shower I mean, do you have Do you have energy Do you have energy like this All day, every day? No
是个狗屎 是的，但谁不是呢？洗完冷水澡后就是个狗屎 我是说，你有没有 你有没有这种能量 你是不是一整天、每一天都充满这种能量？ 没有
When I'm at home And I'm not I'm working And I'm alone I'm very quiet Very like Reserved Even like when I'm
当我在家里的时候 我没有在工作 并且我独自一人时 我非常安静 非常……内向 甚至比如当我
With my man I'm very quiet He has to talk You talk to me And then I'll talk back Like I'm very Like Contempt
和我的男人在一起时 我也非常安静 他必须说话 你跟我说话 然后我才会回应 就像我非常 满足
When I'm not at work Would you say you're an introvert? Because I know I am No No, because if I see something That I'm into I'm gonna I light up
当不在工作的时候 你会说你是个内向的人吗？因为我知道我是 不 不，因为如果我看到什么 我感兴趣的事 我会 我会整个人亮起来
Yeah But most of the time I'm on like I'm trying to keep Maintaining my energy So Yeah I'm quiet
是的 但大多数时候 我处于……我在努力保持 我的能量 所以 是的 我很安静
A lot of the time Till you talk to me Yeah But introvert No Because maybe when I was younger Yes Yeah
大部分时间都是这样 直到你跟我说话 是的 但内向？不算 因为也许自我更年轻的时候 是的 是的
Because I was scared A lot of the times Yeah Fear makes you Like It's risky You know It feels like you flipped
因为我曾经很害怕 很多时候 是的 恐惧让你……这很冒险 你知道 感觉就像你把
All that fear Like you used Yeah I learned how to control fear Yeah Yeah, you used the fear Like fear is a tool God gave it to us
所有的恐惧都转化了 就像你用过的那样 我学会了如何控制恐惧 是啊 是啊，你利用了恐惧 就像恐惧是一个工具 上帝赐予我们它
For a reason For using Right How to use it But that's also why I don't do scary movies Because I know That that shit
是有原因的 为了去使用它 如何去使用它 但这也是为什么我不看恐怖片 因为我知道 那种狗屎
That fear feels real And I'm gonna take that home And then Yeah Yeah Shit It's like I love a good drama
那种恐惧感觉太真实了 我会把它带回家 然后 是的 是的 妈的 就像我喜欢一部精彩的剧情片
Because I'm about that drama But woo That scary demons and shit Woo I wanna quickly just Tiffany ask you about your new movie Talk to us a little bit about your movie Well talk to us about
因为我就好这口剧情片 但哇哦 那些吓人的恶魔之类的 哇哦 我想快速地 蒂芙尼，问问你关于你的新电影 和我们聊聊你的电影吧 好的，跟我们聊聊
Which one Which one do you want to talk about Which one do you want to talk about Your choice You've got so many movies Well Here today just came Outstreaming
哪一部 你想聊哪一部 你想聊哪一部 随便你挑 你有那么多电影 呢 几天前刚上映流媒体
It's now streaming It's a movie with Billy Crystal and I It's very powerful comedy Dramity I would say I saw the trailer for that It looks great Yeah It's really great
现在正在流媒体热播 这是我和比利·克里斯托主演的一部电影 这是一部非常有力度的喜剧 悲喜剧，我可以说 我看过那部电影的预告片 看起来很棒 是啊 真的非常棒
I wanna see that It's very moving You need to be prepared to laugh And potentially cry a little bit Because this is about a man That's going through dementia And about a woman who sees him And realizes he doesn't have
我想看那部 非常感人 你得做好笑的准备 还有可能要偷偷抹几滴眼泪 因为这是一个关于一个男人 正在经历痴呆症 的故事，以及一个看到他并意识到他没有
The help that he needs And she wants to help She wants to be a service He's one of our greats I bet you enjoyed working with him Oh my God I learned so much Yeah
他所需要的帮助 的女人，她想帮忙 她想去付出 他是我们最伟大的演员之一 我敢打赌你和他合作得很开心 哦天哪 我学到了很多 是啊
I learned so much So Card counters coming out in September I'm going to the Venice Film Festival To be my first time ever going to Venice Oh wow It's a Sean and I have been there together
我学到了太多了 所以《算牌人》将在九月份上映 我要去威尼斯电影节 这将是我有史以来第一次去威尼斯 哦，哇 肖恩和我一起去过那里
Sean and I went to Venice together It's beautiful Years ago You'll love it Any tips, any advice They told me I can only bring One person with me But I'm gonna pay to bring other people
肖恩和我一起去了威尼斯 那里很美 几年前的事了 你会爱上那里的 有没有什么小贴士、什么建议 他们告诉我我只能带 一个人跟我去 但我要自费带其他人去
Yeah Like hair and makeup Right Yeah of course Security Any advice You know what We took the boat out to some
是的 比如发型师和化妆师 对吧 是的，当然 还有安保 有什么建议 你知道吗 我们坐船去了一个
Location near Venice And saw some church that was built Thousands of years ago I highly recommend it I'll text you with more Specific information No that sounds pretty specific Nice tip
靠近威尼斯的地点 参观了一座建于 几千年前的教堂 我强烈推荐 稍后我会发短信给你 告诉你更具体的信息 不，听起来挺具体的 很好的建议
You ever work for Fedors? So yeah My recommendation is just bring Some rubber boots Because the water level is rising There Yeah But it's beautiful
你给费多尔工作过吗？ 所以，是的 我的建议是带上 一双胶靴 因为水位正在上涨 那里 是的 但它真的很美
Just enjoy all of it I mean it's unbelievable Tiff thank you for being here today And also thank you for Such For being open like you always are And inspiring Not just me and us
尽情享受这一切吧 我的意思是，这太不可思议了 蒂芙尼，谢谢你今天来到这里 还有，谢谢你 如此 毫无保留地像往常一样坦诚 并且激励了
But whoever is listening to this You really are such a magnet Incredible story Of will Thank you You're an incredible story An incredible person I agree with Sean
不仅是我和我们 还有听这期节目的所有人 你真的是一个磁铁般的灵魂 不可思议的意志力 故事 谢谢你 你是一个不可思议的故事 一个不可思议的人 我同意肖恩的看法
You're a special person So this has been awesome Having you here today So thank you so much I'm gonna go the other way on this Hold on a second Tiffany I find it all very No
你是一个特别的人 所以今天能邀请你来真是太棒了 太谢谢你了 我要换个话题了 等一下，蒂芙尼 我觉得这一切都非常……不
I absolutely agree And just so happy That you spent some time with us today And we're so generous With your story And your Well thank you Well I'm always open to share
我完全同意 很高兴 你今天花时间陪我们 并且如此慷慨地 分享你的故事和…… 哎呀，谢谢你 好吧，我总是乐于分享
And I look forward to working with you all At some point Yeah likewise Will? Yes Steve God bless Jason I can't wait to work with you
并且我期待着在某个时刻 与你们所有合作 是的，彼此彼此 威廉？ 是的 史蒂夫 上帝保佑 杰森 我迫不及待想跟你合作了
Did you guys come out with another season of Ozark Because I want to know what the fuck happened We are working on it now To bet you first part of next year it'll be out And Sean and I We're gonna do a sketch show together Correct Sean? Yes that is correct
你们拍了新一季的《黑钱胜地》吗？因为我想知道到底发生了什么 我们现在正在制作中 我敢打赌明年上半年它就会上映 并且肖恩和我 我们要一起做一个小品秀 对吗，肖恩？ 是的，完全正确
One of these days We made a deal together And we're gonna do a sketch show I would watch the hell out of that Because I'm like What the hell is going on COVID happened And shut the whole thing down
总有一天 我们达成了协议 我们要一起做一个小品秀 我超级想看那个 因为我觉得 到底发生了什么 COVID爆发了 把整个计划都打断了
But it's gonna happen We gotta make it happen We are I'm gonna make it happen Let's all meet at the supermarket We'll meet at the new supermarket And we'll work it all out Let's do it
但它一定会发生的 我们必须让它发生 我们会的 我一定会让它发生的 我们一起在超市碰头 咱们去那个新超市碰头 然后把这事儿定下来 冲吧
We'll see you at the co-op Alright Tiffany my god Thank you so much Love you See y'all later Bye Tiffany thank you Bye Tiffany
我们在合作社见 好吧，蒂芙尼，天哪 非常感谢你 爱你 你们回头见 拜拜 蒂芙尼，谢谢 拜拜，蒂芙尼
Bye sweetie Bye Bye bye What a sweetheart I will say We got along so great And I love spending time with her We got to spend a bunch of time together
拜拜，甜心 拜 拜拜 真是个甜心 我得说 我们相处得太融洽了 我很享受和她在一起的时光 我们花了很多时间在一起
Over the course of a few weeks And we laughed so much And had so much fun And she does have a magnetic personality She really does So authentic So funny So authentic
在短短几周的时间里 我们笑得前仰后合 玩得超级开心 而且她确实有一种充满吸引力的个性 真的有 那么真实 那么有趣 那么真实
So honest And those are my favorite stories Of all time I love those stories People really lifting themselves up And making stuff happen You know my therapist calls those types of people Figure it outers
那么坦诚 而这些是我有史以来最喜欢的 故事 我太喜欢这些故事了 人们真正振作起来 创造出一番成就 你知道我的治疗师把这类人叫做 “解决问题的人”
And she goes Oh you are a figure it outer Sean Your therapist sounds like a real genius Yeah it sounds like Real way with words Do you get a deal on this one? What happened?
然后她说“哦，你就是一个解决问题的人，肖恩” 你的治疗师听起来真是个天才 是啊，听起来很有文采 你在这个上面有提成吗？怎么回事？
We just left 20 bucks an hour Never tell anybody else that story Is my advice to you I will 20 bucks an hour And that's a break for me It's usually 25 or something Oh boy
我们刚把价格砍到20块钱一小时 别把这个故事告诉任何人 这是我对你的忠告 我会的 20块钱一小时 这还是看在我的面子上 通常是25块钱左右 噢，天哪
I talked her down But Tiffany Yeah I love her Tiffany is amazing And all the stuff she does And you know she's I heard that she was Trying to put this supermarket together
我把价格砍下来了 但蒂芙尼 是啊 我爱她 蒂芙尼太棒了 她做的所有事情 还有你知道的，她……我听说她 试图建立这个超市
Back in her community Where she grew up And I'm so into that I really want to get involved somehow No kidding Me too By the way
在她成长的那个社区里 而我太喜欢这个主意了 我真的很想以某种方式参与进去 不是吧 我也是 顺便说一句
People listening are like Yeah I listen to these guys Who probably never do it It's for real Like she's Yeah no I'm serious Yeah same same same Jason doesn't want to do it
听节目的听众会想 是啊，我听这些家伙说 结果可能永远也不会付诸行动 这是真的 就像她……是的，不，我是认真的 是的，一样一样一样 杰森不想干
No you know what I'm doing I find myself sitting here Trying to think of How can I work a buy into this thing And you know it's I should be thinking about the conversation And not about trying to figure out How to say goodbye
不，你知道我在做什么吗 我发现自己坐在这里 绞尽脑汁地想 怎么才能把“买”（buy）这个词植入到这段对话里 呢，你知道的 我本该专注于谈话的 内容，而不是绞尽脑汁去想
In a creative You're trying to work out Yeah I'm trying to think like What's in a supermarket That starts with a buy Well just about everything You can buy Buy
如何以一种有创意的…… 你在努力想呢 是啊，我在想 超市里有什么东西 是以“买”字开头的 差不多每一样东西 你都可以买（buy） 买
Ah God that's right Right there Bye Smart Plus Smart Plus
啊天哪，对啊 就在那儿 拜（Bye） SmartLess SmartLess
SmartLess is 100% organic And artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf Bennett Barbaco And Michael Grant Terry The next episode will be out in a week Wherever you listen to podcasts Or you can listen to it right now
SmartLess 是 100% 有机的 由 Rob Armjurf Bennett Barbaco 和 Michael Grant Terry 手工匠心打造 下一期节目将在两周内发布 无论你在哪里听播客 或者你现在就可以收听
Early on Amazon music Or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry app SmartLess There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在亚马逊音乐上抢先收听 或者通过 Wondry App 订阅 Wondry Plus SmartLess 本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。